bruce willis's family reveals his
devastating health diagnosis
on wednesday the 67 year old actor's
wife emma his ex-wife demi moore and
daughters rumor scout tallulah mabel and
evelyn shared a joint statement on
instagram writing that they had news
they wanted to share as a family quote
our beloved bruce has recently been
diagnosed with aphasia which is
impacting his cognitive abilities as a
result of this and with much
consideration bruce is stepping away
from the career that has meant so much
to him the family adds that this is a
really challenging time and they are
appreciative for fans continued love
compassion and support quote we are
moving through this as a strong family
unit and wanted to bring his fans in
because we know how much he means to you
as you do to him they concluded their
post writing as bruce always says live
it up and together we plan to do just
that
love you dad
scout later posted this pic of her dad
thanking fans for the outpouring of love
and tenderness
according to the mayo clinic aphasia is
a condition that robs you of the ability
to communicate affecting your ability to
speak write and understand language both
written and verbal now a source tells et
that the a-list star struggled filming
one of his last movies american siege in
2021 quote he was unable to remember his
lines
i thought you were in the big house
got out a few hours ago you heard anyone
yet
bruce was supposed to do another film
soon but according to the source he's no
longer working on the project meanwhile
a separate source tells e.t that when
bruce films the movie glass in 2018
production members on that project also
noticed his difficulty remembering lines
david dunn
the only person to survive that train
wreck all those years ago
what do you do i'm insecurity
you think you have superpowers it's a
feeling
vision
i have to touch them you believe you are
a protector e.t was at the premiere for
the flick in 2019 and while bruce walked
the red carpet he didn't speak to the
press but his castmates did and had
nothing but praise for the hollywood
icon to obviously be part of split and
to be
involved with telling the story in this
trilogy i mean it's like i was geeking
out as a fanboy myself you got sam and
bruce who they've been doing this
forever and it was awesome i mean i
think
i definitely had to pinch myself when
i woke up in a room and it was with all
of these incredible actors reprising
roles that were so iconic not just to me
but the entire world
it was sort of a please don't let it be
my time to talk please don't let it be
my time to talk oh god i have a line i
gotta have a line and then we all got to
know each other we get along so well
that it's just it's family at this point
[Music]